as logan gilbert toes the slap tonight
for scott service danny's making his
15th start of the season yeah logan
slowly
really earning that reputation as one of
the best rookie pitchers in the major
leagues you see 67 and a third inning 79
strikeouts and that ball lined into left
field that's a base hit
and hernandez
is aboard
he's three for six against gilbert this
year runner does go whoa up and in and
that one's tight
and
no throw offered on the stolen base
by hernandez
so his first big league stolen base he
did a nice job of getting
to the bag and plenty of time and it
also had to do with the pitch it was a
high fastball but it was so far up and
in that murphy just decided not to go
ahead and throw it
into left field dylan moore gets to
start out there tonight routine out
number three and that single by
hernandez goes no further we go to the
bottom of the first and it's colby aller
getting that start tonight 13th start of
the season 23rd game overall for him 2-0
that ball hit hard center field
adolescence back near the wall he makes
the catch
now plenty room out there two away
didn't he rob a home run here i believe
i'm not mistaken in this ballpark we're
only played in 72 games and he only hit
17 home runs
on the ground ball actually not
not all that
hard hit
and seeger rolls out to in the inning 11
pitches for ali good job of jamming the
hitters
inside at 96 and logan gilbert picks up
his first strike out of the ball game
all right so jason martin
he'll go after the first pitch and that
ball's pounded deep out to right it is
gone
and that one off the facing of that
sweets area or restaurant area
out in right field martin's third home
run of the year
a no doubter and the rangers have the
one-nothing lead
an absolute bomb here by jason martin
mentioned logan gilbert will throw that
fastball up he's done it with some
consistency and this is now the eighth
home run that he has allowed this season
allard
has induced two fly ball outs two ground
ball outs the o2 pitch and there's his
first strikeout of the night two away
a good elevated fastball there from
colby allen especially in a two-strike
count a good two-strike slider there you
saw the check swing
on the o-1 slider they decided to try it
again but terry able to hold it up the
second time
really ties him up and knots at
third strikeout for logan gilbert
the 1-2
chops it off the plate to j.p chan high
throws it dark to first and logan
gilbert retires the side in
order is it he didn't get any run
support
that one
is a swinging strike by murphy second
strikeout honesty is the best policy
dave
i don't want anybody to ask anybody
pretty big swing but got underneath this
one and peters makes the play out and
right and it's another one two three for
colby allard the left-hander looking
pretty good
dotsome up at the knees at 95.
strikeout number four for logan gilbert
a really good pitch here
by logan gilbert we've seen him use the
top of the zone so much and
low anticipating that he would see a
fastball probably up in the zone so this
one down at the knees just locks him up
oftentimes that's the best strike you'll
see to hit well that was nasty
back-to-back strikeouts for logan
gilbert against the barnes and a clean
fourth
mitch hanigar leads off the home fourth
a lift to left
carrying back back and this is gone into
the bullpen
haniger has tied his career high his 26
home run
leads off the fourth and ties this game
at one
and mitch hanigar puts that good swing
on it
stays through the curve ball it will hit
it in the bullpen 101 miles an hour off
the bat
slammed out to right and back to back
and now seeger his 25th
and the mariners have taken the lead in
the fourth
well for hanniger it's the curve ball
for kyle sieger it's the slider
we talked about making mistakes on the
plate this is a slider that's middle
middle away
straight up on the infield the o2
and that strike three call
terence back to the dugout and that is
the third strikeout now
for colby
and then make sure it sounds unfair
don't miss the mistakes down in the zone
well that one on the ground and through
into right field base hit
so
maybe
maybe a little adjusted
that's right he wants some baseball and
for jonah after what turned out to be i
think an old for 20 after his first
half-bat with 10 strikeouts he's back
so one out
this one lined out to right field that's
a base hit hannigar can't cut it off
it's into the corner time into third
base beasley sends him to the plate here
comes a relay
and they had him but they couldn't hold
on to it
murphy dropped it
and the rangers have tied it on the
double
by dj peters colby could really use as a
ground ball seems like the changeup is
set up perfectly here
on the ground to second base one on to
first got him double play
well he got that ground ball when he
needed it
and allard out of the inning no damage
done and we go to the sixth tonight tied
at two
in the left hill and moore makes the
sliding catch
one gun
well hernandez doing what he can with
this fastball and dylan moore just great
concentration with the slide and able to
steal a base hit from yani hernandez so
wild pitch puts the go ahead run in
scoring position with two outs
covering some ground cutting across he's
able to get up over and make the catch
go ahead run is stranded at second
so toro has been hit by a pitch and fly
to right switch hitter batting right
good pitch
strike out of toro
and that is the second out of the inning
good quick pace here for colby allard
against toro who as you mentioned has
been red hot coming into this game paul
seawall the right-hander will take over
you get sedolis garcia first pitch
swinging that ball's hammered deep out
to center it is gone
garcia with a ninth inning home run has
put the rangers in front three to two
well it's up to spencer patton now on
the night a pitch outside the zone here
ties it up
we are tied
vases loaded walk
martin now will be asked to get that
final out here
it's a fastball
and seeger lifts it into center field
and we've got extras
oh my goodness eighth and ninth place
hitters leading off the inning with the
man at second
here's a hard ground ball that one threw
into right field base hit martin rounds
third here comes the throw it's offline
martin scores
rbi single gives the rangers the 4-3
lead
this ball out into left field that one's
sinking quickly and it's trapped out
there by fraley two runs are in and the
rangers lead it 5-3 france leads it off
mariners down a pair lay standing right
field seeger putting on the jets he's
coming around kyle seeger scores
standing
ty france his third knock tonight
he hits this one sharply onto the grass
and right and hernandez throws him out
at first
and the ball game is over